bene tutti i ragazzi dj oggi siamo
tornati su the forest col cappellino di
angri per fare da un bel pezzo
non l'ho fatta tull hanno aggiornato
dieci volte nel mentre che non l'ho
giocato quindi ragazzi sono curioso di
vedere che cosa ha cambiato di cosa
hanno aggiunto di nuovo perché ha dato
questa è ancora più sexy me la ricordavo
sexy ma non così tanto ragazzi se per
che svegliandosi che cazzo
nono sono appena arrivato non rompeteci
ai [ __ ] perfette ragazzi su un
partito ed a due secondi e sono già
nella merda come fantasia questo è bella
gnocca attiva un po di chef solo gli
hotel aereo dietro che caso si corre
ragazzi si stanno incalzando ma non
riescono a salire bellissima amico mio
non solo dirti quanto sei trendy con
questo teschio infilzato nel cranio al
mio tre core diamo verso la spiaggia e
ci tuffiamo in mare come se non ci fosse
un domani ci prova 123 cazzo corri
ma io sto in volta forza the bear grylls
dove sai quando sei arriva all'inizio
dove siamo d'accordo ragazzi fatevi
mettere un attimo tranquillo che devo
vedere che aggiornamenti hanno fatto ci
sono delle capanne
ma non è un buon segno va beh io mi
metto la più qua se ci sono delle
capanne ovviamente c'è anche della gente
da qualche parte è di nuovo al vero col
naso come mai alcuni alberi hanno il
naso cosa fai tu come ti permetti
florido stronzo l'ho preso in pieno non
volatile amici i sensi di colpa condanna
questi animali perché vada non importa
facciamo finta di niente che cazzo cos'è
sta roba
ragazzi è una è un era un tennista no
raga allora ovvia abbiamo finalmente
scoperto da dove arrivano le palline da
tennis ma forse era meglio non scoprirlo
in questi casi si fa la cosa migliore è
possibile
dammi la palla che giochiamo alla roma
ma ti rendi l'amico mio al volo ma non
c'è gusto a giocare con testi troppo
scarso va bene ogni porta ragazza
addio al che vanno a queste tennis di
coppia fantastica comunque io tutto sto
razzismo nei confronti dei tennisti non
ce lo vedo a scoprire che cazzo ci hanno
contrita ai ministri vanno male che ha
smesso di far tennis un po di tempo fa
perché se non c'avevo nel culo pure io
mi sa se un tizio no fermi un attimo c'è
un corpo a terra perché è morto
respirazione bocca a bocca ci penso io
faccio possiamo fare
non è una gnocca allora niente
respirazione mori e atrocemente no no no
no tu vieni qua bastardo vini qui salve
porca [ __ ] via veloce non c'e la cola
cola così perfetto allora io devo
arrivare dall'altra parte dell'isola
prima di venire e squartato quindi se
permettete me ne vado via dalle balle
quindi grazie mille molto gentili però
non rimango a cena quindi animo via
ragazzi devo fermarmi a cucinare un
attimo perché sto morendo di fame non
esco manco più a correre
ora che ci siamo ragazzi fatemi fare un
fuoco che chi cazzo è una coperta ciò
avvenga abbiano preso non ho mancato di
brutto però meno ucciso lo stesso vabbè
gabbiani talpa nuova specie in mancanza
di tavoli usiamo la tovaglia proprio non
sporcare giustamente cosa vi cucina lo
chef fabio oggi la casa certa la rosa è
la cosa giusta assisterò cazzo è quello
da luce cazzo anche perchè c'è un
accampamento mettiamo non fatto a fare
un accampamento a caso c'è va beh io io
vado dove dov'era loro simile non mi
vendono perfetto ragazze sono in
perfetto stile stealth no no merda via
qualcosa mi dice che la meglio se
continuava a farmi kazimiya però va bene
sono dei piedi che spuntano d'asta
roccia che cazzo succede hanno
schiacciato pace all'anima sua ragazzi
non si ride dei morti e per non averlo
avanti e questo è il motivo del perché
non bisogna mai usare i telefoni sono
fuori d'asta grotte perché dovunque vado
vado a finire sempre in una grotta ha
detto delle cose che fluttuano e normale
sul torce or ch non fatevi prendere una
tappa mi chiamano avevo visto questa
sala stampa cenci facciamo un self ci
sono delle torce appesa al soffitto non
me le fa prendere fantastico allora
andiamo avanti di qua ho preso un ascia
più cazzuta fantastico devo riuscire a
trovare ancora la pistola quale l'altra
volta che spaccava i culi di brutto il
problema ragazze che non ha idea di dove
si trovi perché già l'ultima volta mi
sono fatto un culo così
tu sei l'unico pezzo to say no non fatti
c'è sì cioè facciamo una riunione
cos'è sono in paradiso ragazzi sono
imparati oddio dove sto andando
no mourinho stronzo muori muore sono
fini ragazzino non vedo niente
sono finito sul soffitto questi bug
store e poi non ho capito cosa è
successo sono morto però comunque va
bene fantastico se qualcuno di voi
magari avesse voglia di spiegarmi come
cazzo sono morto perché ok
che cos'è quella roba lì ma non è la
guardia quel tizio che cos'è sta roba
questo schifo
qualcuno lo sapevo lo sapevo ma guardate
porte in faccia che ti darei una mela
che avevo salvato se non potevi
incazzarmi ma mi sono incazzato uguale
ragazzi è leggermente un problema questo
comunque noi andiamo via di qui vai via
velocissimo però sta andando ancora più
sintonia prenda di sopra non li sotto
non ho che film workshop [ __ ] ragazzi
se io esco parlamente posso usare l'arco
le faccia farmi le frecce di nomi
nazioni ci sia trovare la [ __ ] uscita
da qualche panno perché da qualche parte
c'è un'uscita sarebbe fantastico
problema è che continua a vedere gente
appesa e uscite non se ne vedono e
magari si incontra qualcuno c'era anche
nel culo cos'è il bengala si riscopre no
no no no no no no no no
sì fuori del cazzo fuori ragazzo ci
aveva i bengala però devi morire ma le
devi morire male tutto a madre fossero
d'accordo ragazzi c'è una missione
pazzesca da fare e parla e folle come
cosa però devo farla e faccio prima le
frecce stavolta ok posso fa 4 che è
fantastico allora adesso l'ho fatto le
frecce mi serve l'arco proprio farlo mi
sarebbe di nuovo il cappio di merda
quindi mi voglio ammazzare in modo da
andare nella caverna prendono e poi
uscire è un macello però ci prova dai
merda dovevi farlo anno c'è gente laggiù
perfetto mi faccio ammazzare la
ragazzina è un tentativo suicida però
devo farlo perché voglio troppo provare
l'arco quindi me ne sbatto questa è
l'ultima volta che mi vedete così la
prova a scappare sì perché io sono badas
tu donna mostra pop e vieni qua niente
scappano tutti adesso mi faccio avanti
che si chiamano tutti addosso come
possibile senti il corridore della
roccia e usciamo un attimo
[Musica]
può essere deficienti ce l'ha fatta a
darmi un corpo [ __ ] che non siete
altro fini che vuole che son dementi e
cioè prima che non volevo morire mi
hanno ammazzato madonna santa prima
veramente in 45 sono venuti addosso a me
adesso io volevo farmi uccidere no
adesso ragazzi la missione se muoio
dover iniziare tutto e potrei incazzarmi
tanto stavolta alla missione trovare un
cappio e la partenza è una merda si si
fosse trovato forse non erano persi
merda pensavo fosse gente appesa al
soffitto mi sono leggermente sbagliato
che cosa non si fa per un arco delle
balle era roba che sai quella roba da
giu cioè io vado dove c'è luce però
perché il terreno è così nervoso e
fatevi trovare una merda nolo non ci
sono capiti male ci siamo capiti male
con un'altra e [ __ ] che cacia farci
già faccio il dribbling il dribbling non
scartato il brutto adesso adesso che ce
la devo trovare solo un posto dove la
gente non mi aggredisca voi lo sapete
che non ce la farò mai trovare uscita
vero è impossibile senza dell'acqua
ragazzi in uscita si rialza ho fatta non
ci posso credere non ci possono non è
possibile non ci voglio ancora cresci
veloce veloce veloce micron un chip no
non è possibile
grande fatica resto al cobà 3 perché
potrei incazzarmi dio mio
benedetto ce l'ho fatta con una mano ciò
l'arco con l'altra ciò l'accendino non
si sa come sia possibile che è una roba
troppo più gli allegati di provare a
prendere qualche come faccio come
bacelega apprende che credono sono
troppo emozionato da questo è bellissima
sta cosa ragazzi hunger games su the
forest dove siamo belle capanne capanne
vuol dire persone persone vuol dire
frecce negli occhi ma emilia il coniglio
coniglio puff [ __ ] co
non ce l'ho mai fatto di prodotto rido
coniglio di merda fuori buon michelon
mancato di pochissimo fermo fermo
libraro bravo che mi immergo che ci lega
non è possibile cioè se sì l'ho preso
una donna che mira a nova san basso ha
vinto ho vinto questo ho visto sono
uscita a cacciare per la prima volta
nella mia vita adesso voglio trovare un
indigeno
sopra impiantarvi la francia in testa
solo quello cazzo che mira di me
sì l'ho preso e non si è fatto una serie
di eni forza vieni stronzo vieni vediamo
se sbaglia la mira adesso circondando no
no vogliono fuori fuori un culo niente
non ce la faccio c'è una mira di merda
devi morire morire niente lo prendo non
c'è verso e ditelo a [ __ ] piano b
piano pip note mila motori pezzo di
stronza ecco adesso adesso vogliamo
chiarite dai forza ridere di sé che la
rsi mans buttato sul fuoco si suicidano
proprio ma che roba
il cazzo l'ho fatto apposta riguarda è
già un miracolo che non mi sono tirato
la freccia addosso ma non importa perché
oltre a chiacchiere che possono
includere qui perche la prossima volta
prova a fare il calciatore più serio che
devo prenderci un attimo la mano questa
roba da parte di questi ragazzi se il
viso è piaciuto ma se questo momento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
non i video tolta la descrizione stasera
vestiti scrivetemi ci dividiamo il
prossimo video ei ragazzi